well how often do I do this huh eight a
soybean
now soybean stuck in my teeth anyways I
have something very important to tell
you guys and this was something that I
wasn't planning to share with you but
I'm gonna do it anyways so as you guys
know in May me the JK family and the SIB
family decided to go to Japan to go
ahead and check out the the first
harvest of our of our matcha leaves for
our matcha tea company now during this
trip I did something very interesting I
proposed to the love of my life that's
right I'm engaged oh that's right you
boys engaged some engaged I'm an engaged
man now I know what you guys are
thinking hold on a second you proposed
to Muriel around May so why are you
telling us now here's the thing and I
don't want anybody to take too much
offense to this but really none of your
[ __ ] business
clearly I'm half joking but this is what
I mean by that when I decided to propose
to Muriel this was a moment that I
wanted to keep to myself and also with
her and a few of our other friends and
the reason why is because being on this
platform I feel like not with everybody
but there is a good handful of people
that feel like they deserve to know
every little [ __ ] thing about my life
and the interesting thing is they go
well you know what David you tell all
these stories why not to share this with
us don't you think it's a little selfish
no it's not [ __ ] selfish it's my life
and here's the here's the thing about it
I choose to share things that I want to
share there's this thing with youtubers
that I feel like when it comes to our
relationship we're we're a lot more
tangible than traditional celebrities
right because we've grown up with you
since day one until now like I've met
people who I've been with have given
them advices they were a preteen till
now when they're in college and even
after college where they're pursuing
their own careers but the thing about
everything that I've done on this
channel is that I chose what I wanted to
give out so just because you've seen my
videos for seven to eight years it
doesn't mean that you get to pick and
select what you want out of my life
that's not really what that's about
I choose to share things with you guys
when I want to and what I'm comfortable
with it just like you guys had that same
choice listen at the end of the day
there are a lot of things that
I don't get to keep special for me and
Muriel right and obviously you guys were
gonna know about this obviously you were
gonna know about the engagement and the
proposal but I wanted to do it on my
time because I wanted this moment just
to even if it's like two or three months
I wanted that moment just to be a me and
her thing and a close family and friends
thing and it felt special it felt great
but fortunately for me and through the
advice of Steve Steve actually told me
that he wished that he recorded the
moment that he proposed to Nicky and the
reason why he didn't do it because he
didn't want to be like one of those
people that were just fishing for views
and they for sure wanted to put up the
proposal because it was gonna make them
a lot of money but at the same time if
we kind of just delete that part out of
it and we say hey I just want to record
this moment so like to look back at the
first time that I asked his woman to be
with me for the rest of my life and so I
took his advice and I did this clip and
you guys are about to see there's
nothing really edited about it it's just
a moment in time where she and I shared
this very private moment and you guys
it may not be exciting for a lot of you
but it's something that when I look back
at it and I see the footage it's it's
very genuine and sincere and now that
I've had my time with Muriel to enjoy it
with just between me and her now you
guys get to see it too so hope you guys
enjoy this
yeah
we could see ourselves
very cool
I bought something for convenience
very very special
[Applause]
I told you awake
[Music]
I told you to wait stop casing
[Laughter]
[Music]
now you're finally engaged
I should have some crazy speech returns
but I don't have anything else up
I didn't either nice bike that I know
cuz I was like oh where should we go cuz
if I felt that if I was trying to plan
things
it would seem too obvious
oh my god are you recording recording it
well where was my ring it's already
March I don't see my freakin ring I was
like I was like I already pottery bah
blah blah goodbye I decided to shut you
up
Oh cuz you've been so annoying
[Music]
Oh
I think I just looked round
[Music]
No
[Laughter]